الى مصر هناك موضوع شائك جدا تعيد فتحه
بين الحين والاخر حالات سيدات تعرضت
حياتهن للخطر رغم القانون يقفل الرعايه
الصحيه للمواطنين ويجرب الامتناع عن
تقديمها ترفض مستشفيات اجراء عمليات
بالنساء دون موافقه ازواجهم طبعا ولايه
الجسد مشاهدينا هكذا يسميها البعض هذه
القواعد المتعارف عليها بين المشافي
والاطباء خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالحياه
الانجابيه في نفس الوقت ايضا تجد من يدافع
عن حق الاطباء في الحصول على موافقه الزوج
بحجه الاطباء يواجهون غضب الازواج اذا
اجروا اي جراحه دون موافقتهم او علمهم حتى
يصل الامر الى لجوء بعض الازواج لمقاضاه
الاطباء والمستشفى
يعني انا عندي وجهه نظر انا شايفه انه اي
عمليه جراحيه تخص الرجل او المراه هي حاجه
تخص جسده فهو له القرار الاول والاخير
فيما يتم في جسده في حين انه لو الموضوع
على المقابل لو الرجل يتم يقوم بعمل عمليه
جراحيه وتمس حياته الزوجيه مع مراته ما
بياخدش اذن يعني القانون هنا بتاع الولايه
يخص ولايه الرجل على المراه انما مش العكس
بحجه انه ده يخص العلاقه الزوجيه ما بينهم
خصوصا في قضيه استئصال الرحم بتاع المراه
يتطلب موافقه الزوج طيب لو العكس لو الزوج
هو هيعمل عمليه جراحيه والاطباء هم اللي
قالوا كده والعمليه دي هينتج عنها انه هذا
الرجل هيبقى ميقدرش ينجب هل هياخدوا اذن
الزوجه طالما هياثر طالما حجتهم ان هو ده
بياثر على العلاقه الذريه مش بياخذوا
طالما القانون هنا مش متساوي يبقى انا
ارفضه هل المشكله ما زال ولكن فيما يتعلق
بانه لا يوجد قانون يضبط
طبعا السلوك الزوج او في حال انه تم اجراء
عمليه لزوجته بدون علمه فيذهب للتهجم على
الاطباء وعلى الكادر الطبي في المستشفيات
ولا راضع لذلك فهل اذا وجد قانون بهذا
الشكل تحلى المشكله اولا لازم اوضح للساده
المشاهدين ان الموضوع اكبر من ذلك وليس في
مصر وحدها بل فئه في الولايات المتحده
ايضا على فكره
الولايه القانونيه على الجسد موضوع كبير
جدا لا يخص فقط العلاقه بين الذكر والانثى
في الزواج او غير الزواج احنا عندنا ولايه
قانونيه للانسان على جسده في حالات فقد
الاهليه زي المسجون قال له الحق في ان هو
يمضي
كونسنت يعني موافقه مستنيره لاجراء بتر
مثلا او فعل في اثناء فتره سجن ولا لا ثم
ناتي الى مشاكل مثلا زي الاجهاض الاجهاض
مشكله في كل انحاء العالم تعريفه ومن له
الولايه القانونيه على الجنين هل هو للاب
ام للامه هل هي حريه للام في اجهاض نفسها
ولا لا يعني فكره الاستئصال الرحم كموضوع
هو موضوع صغير جدا جدا في مشكله كبيره جدا
طب خلينا هذا الموضوع دكتور خالد ركز على
الحريه اذا تكرمت نركز عليه الان لماذا
يعني هذه
الطلبات زي ما حضراتكم قلتم هو لا يوجد
قانون لكن هناك سوابق قضائيه من الازواج
رفعه وقضايا ضد اطباء وتم الحكم فيها
لصالح هؤلاء الازواج انهم لم يحصلوا على
موافقتهم في استئصال رحم او مبايض او شيء
في زوجته لماذا هذه التفرقه
كما طرحتها الاستاذ نيفين عندما لا يوجد
نص قانوني بيترك للقاضي يعني لضمير القاضي
الحكم في القضايا
[موسيقى]